[Music]
you know during the past 50 years all of
us have witnessed extraordinary advances
in science and technology development of
magnetic core memory transistors
high-speed computing personal computers
telecommunications development and
expansion of the internet cell phones
and biomedical area antibiotics
identifying the viral causing human
diseases leads of vaccines that have
actually eliminated scores Courage's
like like polio the emergence of genetic
engineering in the biotechnology
revolution many new forms of diagnostics
and therapies landing and returning in
the moon sending satellites past the
rings of Jupiter which contributed to
the climate science that allowed the
scientists to recognize what's happening
at the scientific level all of that what
those advances were the products of the
very large public investments our income
tax dollars voted by congressional
committees and investors with the
National Institutes of Health National
Science Foundation National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration and many
investments in higher education in my
work with graduate students I'm often
struck that they think this was always
there he always got paid to go to
graduate school there was always grants
available to pay for research
technicians and and equipment and they
don't realize that all those programs
were the outcome of social struggles
like the civil rights struggles like
women's rights struggles and many people
don't know that because it weren't very
dramatic but in fact prior to World War
two very few American got to college at
all and if you look at how many were
learning chemistry or math or physics
extremely small numbers but too few even
to produce high school teachers who
could who could teach those those those
disciplines then World War two broke out
and World War two generated
technological crisis higher higher
proximity fuze
I need for a high-altitude maneuvering
radar etc but there was a serious
shortage of technical personnel and the
government under Roosevelt came up with
a brilliant solution they organized the
office of scientific research and
developments resisting the charge that
they were Reds and socialists and the
OSRD brought identified all around the
United States
those small number of people at
scientific and engineering training got
them draft deferments got him a ticket
MIT has the status it has now because
the radar project was located here
scientists are all over the country were
brought MIT and funded to do that work
when the war ended they stayed here then
there are a number of kind of knock-down
drag-out battles the biomedical research
had been very successful discovery of
penicillin and large-scale manufacture
the National Institutes of Health was
established to distribute research money
throughout the country National Science
Foundation to distribute research funds
for scientists around the country and
the GI Bill which allow two point two
million GIS to go back to college and
paid faculty salaries and rents and
allowed the college and university
system to expand second shock which many
of you remember was Sputnik in 1957
right after Sputnik we got NASA NOAA
National Defense Education Act which
paid high school teachers to upgrade
this Vance laboratory equipment etc I
won't go into it it's the budget
national budget for kind of basic
science now around 33 billion which only
3% of the total congressional budget but
it supports graduate students and in
universities all across the country
right up there around a hundred thousand
is in all different areas most people
still think that if you're a graduate
student and by
chemistry you pay MIT no your tax
dollars pay MIT graduate students get
paid they get a stipend they get tuition
but that money is the skill is the
foundation of this extraordinary
creative scientific infrastructure
now there's the 2015 congressional
budget fifty five percent to the
military science thirty 1 billion three
three percent when I show this slide
most people don't believe it
they feel well I'm an educated person if
it was really true that fifty five
percent of my tax dollars went to the
military I'd know that no they don't
know that no agency the government
writes back to you about how your taxes
was spent right you ask people on Essex
Street in my neighborhood how much of
your taxes went to military Oh 10% 15%
20% we think if people knew how how big
that number was right that they would
have a very different attitude now the
situation as you know as you've all read
the papers this morning
Trump's going to make it worse right
much worse he's going to cut all of
these programs like the NIH like you EPA
to finance 54 billion more on the
military side it's a direct transfer of
wealth from the majority who are paying
taxes to a small number of corporations
who will get these contracts we heard
about that this morning the most
profitable sector of us in industry
monopoly because you can't offshore it
to China cost-plus by congressional
mandate and it can't be audited right by
because of national security so if
you're building submarines you are
guaranteed juicy profits enormous sums
of money all you have to read is the
press releases that the corporation's
release the kind of Wall Street when
they get these contracts now by the way
they were very clear look at the second
quote that's
from veiny the director of the budget in
talking to Republican governors were not
happy with some of the domestic cuts by
a way of defending such extensive cuts
mr. Lowell veiny said simply that the
White House's variety was military
spending other reductions would
necessary to advance that goal it's
clear right they're going to cut the
National Institutes of Health
we got millions of people suffering from
Alzheimer's we're at the point where we
could find cures now forget it we're
going to build more submarines and more
missiles now two weeks ago was the march
on science it was thrilling it was the
first time in my life and I've been at
MIT for forty-five years it was the
first time I had ever seen graduate
students and postdocs in large numbers
out marching with their wonderful
science now they were marching they
believed in science they also knew that
what that cuts mean is the day we can be
laid off right look they're going to be
off because that's what that money pays
for pace of salary for people by then
the equipment is expensive but not that
much but I know 20,000 people at the
common but the leadership was I would
say limited there was no scientific
analysis of what forces are leading to
this anti stir cutting the scientific
budget in fact no speaker was allowed to
mention Trump within the administration
right so those graduate students who
they want to fight for the NIH budget
but they need to know that the NIH
budget is being cut in order to build
nuclear submarines right if they knew
that I think their attitude towards a
nuclear submarines might develop and in
in more critical ways so that's true
across the board if you go to you go to
a housing meeting and say don't worry
about housing the world's about to get
blown up by a nuclear first strike so
hey I'm about to lose my house that's a
big enough possess'd for me right now we
have to go and say well with you when
affordable housing in the richest
country on earth we need a much more
affordable housing why don't we have it
because we're taking the money and we're
building these weapons we have to
actually make clear that those things
are inextricably connected if you want
decent subways in in Boston you're gonna
have to oppose taking your tax dollars
and building submarines and saying for
health care Medicare etcetera so I'm
just going to close that every one of
you had in your in your folder a folded
over brochure fold over brochure
it says build housing not bombs subways
not submarines invest in mine's not
missiles these are not empty slogans
this is the mechanism to forge the
relationships and the alliances that we
need to forge to get millions of people
to oppose nuclear weapons and not not
thousands and we're making a good start
here
and I hope we keep it up so thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]